françois blanchet bonjour bien bonjour
alors bonnes performances ou pas qu'est
ce qu'aurait dit là l'ex analyste du
crif 10 aix de rdi sur votre père force
c'est une excellente question qu'est ce
que j'aurais dit j'aurais certainement
dit que le chef du bloc a réussi à
contenir le tempérament qu'on lui prête
les gens l'attendaient probablement plus
agressif que ce soit mais les ex ont été
une expérience très utile parce que
jamais sur le plateau d aix on
s'insultait les uns les autres
pas pour moi une discussion qui prend la
forme d'un débat doit exclure le manque
de respect envers les autres et je pense
que ça a été très très formateur même si
les chefs ne sont pas tous aussi
sympathique que marie guyot l'a sûrement
pas quand même mais vous avez appelé les
québécois hier à voter pour un parti qui
leur ressemble et journaliste anglophone
de city vit en fait a demandé ce matin
monsieur un joe scheer
s'il y avait une connotation raciste
dans vos propos qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça a priori simplement non
depuis avec le mouvement nationaliste au
sens très large au québec est toujours
sur le bord de se faire accuser de
racisme de xénophobie d'exclusion alors
que nous tout notre campagne est marquée
par le fait que quelqu'un qui est au
québec et qui vivent au québec est un
québécois
un québécois c'est pas quelqu'un qui
votent pour le bloc québécois c'est pas
quelqu'un qui parle français en suspens
la maison ça rien à voir avec eux c'est
quelqu'un qui dit par contre je
comprends que la langue commune celle
france qui conscients des valeurs
fondamentales des québécois mais alors
qu'est ce que vous vouliez dire
précisément hier soir moi je pense que
la fête dans une campagne électorale on
présume d'un propos quand dean touristes
le garçon comme ça quand on dit exemple
québec c'est nous c'est c'est une
volonté de rassembler puis pour nous
c'est le moins que l'usld est vrai été
galvaudé mais pour nous bien sûr c'est
une notion qui est accusé mais accuser
les nationalistes québécois les 70 % de
québécois qui soutiennent la loi
québécoise sur la laïcité d'être
racistes ou xénophobes ou qu'aux gens
c'est grossier et ça suggère que
monsieur chiffres non sous la halle
électoraux québécois pour se concentrer
sur les lecteurs de loi
avec une crainte importante c'est que ça
prenne la forme d'une campagne
électorale dont le fondement est de
taper sur les québécois pour marquer des
points à l'extérieur du québec et ça ça
pour vrai le mot divisive s'applique ici
alors que moi je prétends que les
québécois et les canadiens devraient
être plutôt de bons amis plutôt que de
mauvais partenaire fort c'est l'essence
même du blog c'est bien de défendre de
promouvoir la souveraineté à ottawa
est-ce que c'est toujours de la faute du
coup on a entendu parler de souveraineté
hier si je pouvais mais j'entendais les
spéculations des gens qu'ils auraient
europol mou sur 28 pour moi je parle de
souveraineté sur toutes les tribunes où
je vais maintenant il ya deux choses qui
sont très claires de ne pas on ne peut
pas réaliser la souveraineté par des
incantations on peut pas répéter le mot
on sent que ça va arriver parce que
j'avais pété le mot 14 fois dans ma
journée c'est pas de la sorcellerie
c'est de la politique et l'autre élément
c'est il est très clair qui est un
exercice qui doit être complété à québec
c'est l'assemblée nationale du québec
qui va mettre en place un processus
déclarer l'indépendance le coach et nous
on a un rôle essentiellement pédagogique
l'adapt de stimuler puis d'avoir des
idées dans la campagne fédérale actuelle
mois sur toutes les tribunes je parle de
souveraineté mais je ne m'attends pas du
débat des chefs à ce que ce soit un
débat sur la souveraineté
mais quand je les ai au début moi je
mets au défi les chefs des autres partis
de me parler de souveraineté
je serai toujours là pour l'expliquer
mais je dirais pour la date puis je
dirais pour la manière parce que ça ne
m'appartient pas comme chef d'un parti
qui s'en vont au contraire à ottawa
protéger la voix de l'assemblée
nationale protège et la volonté des
québécois tel qu'on perçoit qu'elle
ressort des consensus de cette nation là
et c'est ce qu'on va faire tout en
continuant sur toutes les tribunes à
fine une pédagogie diatonique cote aussi
de ce que les québécois veulent que soit
la souveraineté
donc vous dites au fond le bloc en ce
moment votre rôle sera d'être la voix du
gouvernement du québec à ottawa de
l'assemblée nationale de l'assemblée il
ya toujours ce que je reproche à
personne
c'est indécent de passer deux assemblées
nationales à françois legault ou à quoi
les gens du québec l'assemblée nationale
s'exprime par des votes et c'est le seul
parlement national des québécois donc en
matière d'immigration en matière de
langue française en matière de santé
cette semaine il ya eu un vote unanime
de l'assemblée nationale du québec
pour demander que les transferts du
fédéral à massa de santé soient
rétablies c'est l'assemblée nationale du
québec il nous sommes bien sûr porter de
sow mais si on parle d'environnement
monsieur blanchet sk pas un danger
justement à vous coller sur l'acac parce
que vous dites on est un parti vert plus
vert que les verts même vous avez dit
monsieur ça me fila qu'à la pièce par
contre ne vous opposez pas par exemple
un projet comme gnl québec au saguenay
ne peux pas m'opposer à un projet en
fait gnl ce cas précis ils sont précis
gnl est présentement entre les mains du
bac j'ai été ministre de l'environnement
du québec j'étais le ministre
responsable du bape est ce que je vais
moins allait désavouer le bape a 20 qui
dépose son rapport
je m'attends à ce que le bape disent que
ces points vos projets puisque c'est pas
bon québec prendre ses décisions j'ai
été très clair j'ai aucune sympathie
pour ce projet là l'avenir économique du
québec passe par les énergies
renouvelables la recherche l'innovation
les technologies environnement sic la
filière gazière automatique augmenter le
bien qu'ils pensent que j'ai de l'
enthousiasme à l'endroit de gnf josé
respect non parce que ces deux
juridictions de québec
et parce que je respecte le bape et
l'autorité de l'assemblée nationale du
québec
je ne vais pas dans un autre parlement
pour elle est dicté ma volonté à québec
puisque je reproche aux libéraux et aux
conservateurs et au npd de vouloir
dicter leurs volontés à québec
alors évidemment je me refuse à faire ça
même chose pour les aînés tellement
exclusivement de québec et des villes
que ça touche le fédéral n'a pas
juridiction en matière d'infrastructures
si donc le gouvernement du québec veut
aller de l'avant avec ce jeu par contre
j'suis pas pour je dis que c'est à eux
de le faire mais le bloc et vert ou
n'est pas vers le bloc est un parti au
parlement fédéral
et comme partout parlement fédéral va
respecter la juridiction de québec mais
surtout les enjeux environnementaux qui
relève fédère savez quand on arrive avec
le projet de péréquation verte ça relève
pas de québec
ça relève du fédéral c'est une
révolution et dans la taxation et dans
l'approché environnementale canadienne
aux propositions sur l'électrification
du transport scolaire risque
mal passé par contre votre péréquation
verte dans le reste du pays est le
critère historique s'impose c'est qu'on
puisse démontrer clairement qu'avec un
tel système plutôt que de se faire dire
par jason kenney et son ami un douche il
que le québec vit aux crochets de
l'alberta on va recevoir des sommes
d'argent parce que nous sommes
performants en environnement parce que
nous avons davantage d'énergie propre
parce que nous sommes davantage
sensibles on n'est pas parfait on est
plus sensible aux enjeux
environnementaux
alors on pourra plus le faire cette
espèce de chantage de péréquation comme
si on se faisait vivre aux crochets du
pétrole albertain que nous avons
d'ailleurs au fil des ans largement
subventionnés je pense qu'il faut sortir
de là j'ai vécu mes propres tests en
matière de pétrole
je peux vous dire pour l'avoir vécu il
faut vraiment sortir de l'eau oui mais
est-ce que justement votre passé de
ministre de l'environnement vient pas
entacher un peu votre crédibilité quand
vous parlez l'exploration et le résultat
de ce contentieux piquemal hier à
anticosti entre ce que s'ils étaient un
projet d'exploration doit jamais
dépasser l'étape de l'exploration qui
viserait de l'exploration au fini
peut-être parfois de ce serment passion
on peut flotter quelqu'un qui peut
sortir avec mais lorsqu'on fait
d'exploration c'est pour vérifier la
pertinence et la possibilité mais très
vite après la fin du mandat jean
concerné dans une logique commerciale ou
départ le raisonnement c'était est-ce
qu'on peut utiliser le pétrole empreinte
environnementale moindre pour assurer la
transition vers un autre modèle
économique et le notre modèle
énergétique et rapidement la conclusion
si on n'a pas la maturité pour faire sa
niche québec nik khan a donné l'ensemble
à plaindre que vous regretter de l'avoir
fait à l'époque j'étais dans un
gouvernement est dans un gouvernement on
doit jouer en équipe
j'étais probablement que c'est ma
prétention celui qui retenait le plus
possible le gouvernement dans cette
démarche l'eau les économique du
lendemain
environnement cace
raï était de retenir le plus possible
j'étais convaincu je le suis encore que
les coups auraient été exorbitant et
aucune rentabilité et que la
restauration environnementale eu aucune
infrastructure n'y a pas de route pas de
porc n'y a pas rien les lans que si m6 a
surtout signé la protéger quand même un
environnement protégé vers attention là
dessus des landes ce que ce qui n'est
pas le paradis écologique qu'on décrit
c'est un endroit avec déjà de gros
problèmes environnementaux une soucoupe
l'économie des clauses ou pour protéger
raconte il faudrait y aller c'est pas
c'est pas le jardin d'éden
alors vous dites que vous voulez que
vous sauviez en faveur d'un gouvernement
minoritaire avec qui est ce que vous
aurez plus d'affinités à travailler est
ce que sont les libéraux ou les
concernant d'âge je confie aux québécois
la réflexion à savoir si le gouvernement
doit être majoritaire ou minoritaire
travailler cependant on va voter à la
pièce ce qui est bon pour le québec
on y repos ce qui est mauvais pour le
québec ont ils raconté probablement
quand les deux on négociera sur
l'ensemble des dossiers de une situation
historique où le bloc a envisagé de
s'allier formellement quelqu'un sa
politique en regard des histoires une
bonne idée ne sommes pas un accessoire
d'un parti fédéralisme ne sont pas un
accessoire du fédéralisme canadien est
plus facile pour vous de négocier la
pièce si les conservateurs soutenait
vraiment la déclaration d'impôt unique
on travaille avec les conservateurs
selon style frais non mais voilà sur le
site mais si les libéraux arrivent avec
un véritable projet environnemental qui
me ding détenions pour retravailler avec
eux si les libéraux art est justement de
s'objecter à la déclaration des prévenus
contre parfait on peut collaborer et
quel est le chiffre magique pour sortir
le bloc du cimetière comme pour
reprendre votre arme et ça c'est dur à
dire ça dépend combien chacun des partis
bon moi j'ai aujourd'hui que je me
mettais pour moi même un plancher à 20
pour considérer que l' aventure d'être
venu à la direction du bloc se justifier
que ça allait être un succès je suis
assez optimiste mais je ne permettrai à
personne dans le bloc québécois d'être
le moindrement triomphaliste ou
présomptueux parce que pour l'instant on
a un élan qui semblent positifs et
encore du travail à faire
jours à cette campagne lot tout peut se
produire alors la prudence une
l'humilité et le travail reste de
rigueur
c'est blanche et merci beaucoup ont une
fin de campagne merci